quando somos picados pela fêmea do
mosquito AES egipte o responsável pela
transmissão da dengue inicia-se um
período conhecido como incubação do
vírus geralmente esse período de
incubação ele vai variar de 4 a 10 dias
a febre é o primeiro sinal de alerta
surgindo repentinamente e alcançando
pantamar elevados a dor de cabeça é
outro sintoma marcante da dengue
descrita não apenas como uma dor comum
mas como uma pressão intensa que parece
espremer o interior dos olhos as dores
musculares e nas articulações podem ser
tão severas tão intensas e acompanhadas
de uma fadiga extrema os sintomas
intestinais como nuses e vômitos
adicionam outra camada de desconforto em
alguns casos a doença pode provocar
dores abdominais e embora menos comum
pode estar diarreia também a erupção
cutânea que pode aparecer após alguns
dias de febre é caracterizada por
manchas vermelhas que podem cobrir
grandes áreas do corpo